[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
good evening another record-breaking day
for kovid as omicron begins to spread at
an unprecedented rate over 88 000 new
cases were discovered in the last 24
hours and the new more transmissible
variant will soon be dominant across the
country
so is enough being done to stop omicron
and what exactly do we know about it
well over the next hour we will have the
expertise of a panel of guests including
professor paul moss from the university
of birmingham's institute of immunology
dr raghiv ali an epidemiologist at the
university of cambridge who advises the
government on covert disparities dr
claudia paolini she's president of the
hospital consultants and specialists
association and a consultant
anaesthetist and simon calder the
independence travel editor
well throughout the day we've been
getting your questions about omicron and
we hope to answer as many of those as
possible this is our omicron q a special
we need the uk government to act
urgently
we're not closing things down we're not
asking people to cancel things
omicron is currently running faster than
even the fastest rollout of vaccines
people should be cautious and they
should think about their activities in
the run-up to christmas
where we're going over the next couple
of weeks the rate of increase is going
to be i think fairly impressive
because advisors are now running the
show i'll bet none of them run
businesses facing complete ruin as a
result of what was said last night
british tourists are to be banned from
france from saturday morning were you
planning to go to france for christmas
forget it
hello well professor chris witte warned
earlier of a series of record-breaking
days this winter as we start to see a
wave of omicron cases today was one of
those days with over 88 000 cases
identified
scientists believe that each person
infected with the new variant is passing
it on to a further three to five people
it will soon become the dominant variant
nationwide and in scotland that will be
as soon as tomorrow hospitalizations
from omicron remain mercifully low
that's thanks to the strong vaccine
rollout but with its rapid spread will
that last will it be enough well we'll
be speaking to that panel of experts in
just a moment but first our
correspondent alex rossi reports on
hospitals under pressure
recovering in her hospital bed it's been
a terrible 10 days for lisa king
her breathing is slowly returning to
normal but it was touch and go at times
the 51 year old wishes she'd had the
vaccine and is now urging others to get
the jab i've never experienced nothing
like this in my life
and
it's
nothing i'd want anyone else to him
how are you feeling now
the flow of covid patients at this
hospital has been relentless throughout
the pandemic but two epidemics coming
now on top of each other delta and
omicron they are preparing for worse to
come
this is the intensive care unit where
the most critically ill patients are
brought for treatment
many of the people here are on
ventilators now at the moment the
hospital is coping but the fear is
with the omicron variant
taking off in the community that
hospital admissions will soon rise
sharply
the patients here most likely all have
the delta variants
in one of the beds we meet david colley
a fit 39 year old he has been double
jabbed but still ended up in icu
yeah
i was on the um
i was on the ward for two days i've
deteriorated so i've had to bring me in
here
i've been in here four weeks now today
i've been in here
now go to the gym three or four times a
week
mountain bike
never off sick
it's just just knocked me off my face
now you just say you don't think it's
going to happen
i've been double jabbed
as well
may and july if i was jabbed
and i did say i found the been
vaccinated probably wouldn't be here
for the medical staff these are
frustrating days the vast majority of
patients here have not been vaccinated
with another big wave of infections
coming they are worried about the next
few weeks
so all of the meetings that we've
attended in so far as the network is
concerned where modeling is taking place
the message is clear that this looks
like it's the calm before the storm
government scientists say omicron
infections are now moving at a
phenomenal pace
and at the start of this new wave medics
here are already exhausted
initially it was
all hands on deck everyone was full of
energy
and but as the time's gone on it seems
like there's there's no ending to it
the infectiousness of omicron also
brings new challenges as well as making
more space for patients there is the
risk to those working on the front line
we are absolutely worried about not only
just having enough staff here but also
the impact that it has on staff who are
well having to work additional shifts
having to work that flexibility and to
show that that resilience that we ask
again of our staff again and again
no one here knows what omicron will
bring over the christmas period they
hope the explosion in infection rates
will not lead to a surge in admissions
but the data does not look good
alex rossi sky news
wolverhampton
well there you go that's what it looks
like on the coved wards on the icu uh
awards those crucial days ten days till
christmas uh let's uh talk to our guests
at now about what those might look like
and we have our first question our first
question
what are the symptoms of the omicron
variant and are they easily confused
with a cold i'd like to put that to dr
rajib ali first of all please
good evening
so
we've got some data just today actually
from the kovidzoe app
which has millions of people using it to
look at the
symptoms and preparing those for omicron
versus delta
and also you'll see how common they are
with the cold so the top five symptoms
that have been found
are runny nose headache
uh tiredness or fatigue uh can be mild
can be severe
sneezing and a sore throat and of course
all of us would recognize recognize
those
as very typical symptoms of a cold so
the
the best guess really at the moment is
that if you have those symptoms in
london particularly where omicron is
obviously
or has been
leading the kind of way in london is
where it's most prevalent over 50 of
cases now if you have those symptoms
it is more likely that you've got covet
and particularly omicron compared to a
cold if you do have a symptom that's
really important
and that you do isolate yourself take a
lateral flow test
and a pcr test as soon as you can
so book a pcr test as soon as you can to
check whether you have got covered well
let's just take that in if you are in
london and you have those symptoms runny
nose fatigue etc you are more likely to
have omicron than a cold let's just let
that uh sink in so do get those lateral
flows second question here uh i've had
my booster quite recently how will that
affect my immunity against the variant
i'd like to put that to professor paul
moss please
thank you thanks very much uh important
question yeah i mean obviously the
baseline vaccine was was two doses in
the uk and um at one time we felt that
might get us through the winter there
was debate about boosters we introduced
that a few weeks ago we now know with
this variant that the booster is a vital
weapon
the reason is because i think as many of
your viewers will know that this virus
has mutated so much that it can evade
perhaps up to 40
times of the antibodies that you had
previously that protected you maybe down
from 100 down to two to five percent
you've got to get that level up and
boosters can do that they can boost
antibody levels by 20 30 fold so they're
very powerful weapon
and we've also seen some real world
evidence from south africa that boosters
can give some perhaps 70 protection
against symptomatic infection so they're
vital and it's great to see the booster
campaign working so well across the uk
and we were just a follow-up question on
that when does the immunity uh kick in
at its highest how long do you have to
wait before that booster immunity really
kicks in
well you've already had two baseline
vaccines so you're going to get a rapid
response within the first week um so yes
i'd expect protection to be within the
first one to two weeks okay brilliant
thank you very much uh professor morse
now listen as we are talking about
boosters we're going to take a a short
pause uh there in the questions for a
second the health secretary has just
given an update on the booster rollout
let's have a listen
well look since we learned about this
new variant omicron our strategy has
been to buy time time to assess it and
also to of course build our defenses and
vaccines still remain our best form of
defense now we know now that two doses
of the vaccine are not enough against
omicron but three doses provide
excellent protection and this is truly
now it's a national mission it's a it's
a race between the virus and the vaccine
and that's why i was particularly
pleased to see that yesterday we had our
best booster day ever so far 740 000
booster doses throughout the uk hitting
a new total of 25 million and i want to
thank everyone that's been involved in
that the nhs of course the the military
personnel helping all the thousands of
volunteers and of course everyone that
is enthusiastically coming forward
because this really is our best form of
defense we can see that it's working and
we need more and more people to keep
coming forward take up their chance to
get boosted by the end of this month for
all adults and also really to know that
if they you know answer that call from
the nhs they are protecting themselves
they're protecting their loved ones and
they're protecting their community
um but we don't know just how effective
the booster program is going to be and
chris whitty today implied that there
could be new measures new restrictions
if it turns out that the booster isn't
quite as effective as we all want it to
be
can you tell us what options you're
looking at so people can plan their
lives over the next few weeks well we've
taken measures uh this week there was a
really lively debate in parliament but
the the measures are there now they are
in place and those measures are going to
help and give us a level of protection
but most importantly they help us by
time and and that time is being really
sensibly used to really turbo charge
this booster program now of course that
depends on the fantastic work we're
seeing from the nhs and the volunteers
and they're delivering with this you
know record number of booster doses
wanna keep seeing that number go up and
up but also with people uh coming
forward and i would just encourage
everyone to come forward if they're
eligible and get protected
could you answer the question though
secretary of state can you for instance
rule out any more restrictions in the
next week no we've we've been really
clear about this all along the the
measures we've put in place are the
right set of measures we of course keep
that under review and you know i've said
that and i'm happy to say it again of
course we have to keep the situation the
review and keep looking at the data but
right now what the data is telling us is
that boosters really make a difference
uh they really you know as you would
want you know to really increase your
protection dramatically against this new
variant and that is why it remains our
best form of protection
nicola sturgeon has announced tougher
restrictions in scotland more
restrictions expected in wales tomorrow
why are they wrong
well look we've seen throughout this
pandemic different parts of the uk will
have slightly different
policies on on on mixing and things like
that and that's for each nation to
decide but the one thing that whether
it's scotland it's wales the uk
any part of the uk one thing we all
agree on is the vaccine program and
we've seen everyone really turbo charge
their booster program in particular and
that is something that everyone is
rightly focused on the metropolitan
police have said that they are going to
interview two people in connection to
breaches of covid rules
uh in the con uh that happened at
conservative party events when you see
that news which has just broken how do
you feel
look i think first of all what the
police may or may not do that's an
operational decision
for the police to make but in terms of
some of the news that we've seen
recently especially around downing
street and allegations of what may or
may not have happened what i always
think is you need to establish the facts
and i'm pleased that simon case the
cabinet secretary has been asked to do
just that and can we expect to report
any time soon i'm not sure the exact
timing of the report but i know simon
case would take this issue really really
seriously and i know he will look at it
thoroughly
health secretary sajid javid speaking
there with an update on the booster
program just uh moments ago we're going
to get straight back into your questions
to our panel of uh experts and
interestingly uh the health secretary
they're highlighting uh the difficulty
for people making decisions ahead of
christmas because the data to a large
extent isn't fully in yet so decisions
are having to be made on incomplete data
with that in mind we've got our next uh
question are hospitals prepared for the
normal rise in hospital visits at
christmas time and the rise in omicron
cases so there's sort of two questions
within that let's start with the first
part of that question dr claudio uh
claudia paulini you obviously are at the
cold face of this are you expecting this
christmas
a normal the normal rise in in christmas
visits given that many people might
decide to stay at home and not engage in
the normal socializing and partying that
might lead them to end up in hospital
we have to remember that the hospitals
are already under pressure
if you look at the news that's been
coming up in the previous weeks we can
see that ambulances are queuing up
and every winter we fall under pressure
we run very high occupancy rates higher
than a lot of the other european
countries and we don't have as many
hospital beds in the acute
service
compared to other european countries the
reality is we only have a hundred
thousand acute beds um in the uk and so
there is that is a shared
pressure for everybody we have to treat
not only covert cases we have to treat
all the other urgent cases that come in
with life-threatening conditions that
need quick treatment and at the moment
that is also a problem that we're going
to have to manage so we are indeed very
very worried
okay let's put the second part of that
question to dr rajib ali given what you
know about omicron omicron thus far
how concerned are you about the state of
hospitals over the next uh well i mean
we could say a few weeks but beyond that
so what we're seeing again is london is
really giving us um the best idea of
what's likely to happen across the
country
in the coming days and weeks and what
we've seen in london is a rapid rise in
cases and we have started to see an
increase in hospital emissions as well
in london they're about up about 50 over
the last
two weeks now some of that is still
delta so we still have the delta variant
and that's causing the majority of
possible emissions across the country
but in london it's probably
the proportion of omicron cases and
hospitalizations
is increasing
the key thing in terms of the coming
days as you've mentioned it's important
that people that need to be in hospital
for whatever reason you know if
they've got symptoms or signs of
seriously they must come to hospital we
don't want us to see what happened in
the first and second lockdown in first
and second waves when many people stop
coming into hospital and we're suffering
at home so it's very important people
continue to to come in and and of course
to come in with symptoms of cable as
well if they're if they're seriously ill
but the the key thing in the coming
two weeks is what will be the rate of
hospitalizations of those anachronic
cases and we don't have that
information yet we've got some data from
south africa of course and also from
denmark but it's not directly comparable
to our situation here in the uk i mean
in the uk we have got very high levels
of population immunity mainly for
vaccination and particularly in the
older age groups which will protect us
and
we do know that if you have three doses
you have significant protection at least
75
for symptomatic infection and it'll be
higher than that hospitalizations so
that you know that will help us but the
the thing we're worried about is if
there's a very significant number of
cases in a very short period of time
that could lead to you know the number
of hospital admissions that would really
put the nhs or hospitals in particular
and uh under great pressure and that's
what we're trying to avoid
okay thank you very much i'd like to put
this question because this slightly ties
into what we were talking about with uh
professor paul moss earlier uh the
question is will there be a need for a
second booster soon so that would
effectively be a fourth uh vaccination
is what are your thoughts on that
there's a lot of debate already about
future vaccine policy as i said we
thought we're going to be too and now
we've got the threat potentially of
recurrent vaccines and will we need them
i mean just reflecting on our current
booster policy as we just heard it's
super in many ways uh over 25 million
boosters given and in the older
population who are most at risk we're
getting levels of a 90 booster uptake so
we're doing quite well with our third
booster in terms of your question will
we need another
let me just talk a little bit about a
group that we tend to forget a bit which
is immune suppressed patients which are
up to about 3 million people in the uk
they've already had three primary doses
whereas most the general population had
two so they've had three and they're
eligible now for a booster in three
months so
um they'll be having their fourth very
soon
as for the rest of the population
another booster we just have to assess
it we do need more research on this and
so what we've been doing in this country
is we've got a lot of patients who are
following to look at the level of the
antibodies and cellular responses over
the next few months as i said when we
think of the booster that we've just
currently giving it's not really
something that's holding our immunity at
a certain level it's taking it up to an
extra level it's possible that that
third booster may get us through for
quite a long time but it'd be very
important to see how it clinically
protects against infection and severe
disease
all right thank you very much so that's
very clear uh professor paul moss there
you are watching a sky news omicron q a
special coming up as interest rates rise
omicron looks sec to only worse than the
issues what can we expect in the new
year do stay with us
so the opportunity cost of of not only
being a mortgage prisoner but that
additional rise
you can't even put it into words at the
moment it's it's terrifying
[Music]
well it's worth noting first of all this
is this is a different app to the one
that shows your vaccination status there
are two apps here and this is the
contact tracing app and
people have downloaded this app the idea
is if you get a positive pcr test you
can then use the app you can hit a
little button that says please let my
close contact know that i've tested
positive and they can then take the
appropriate action
and obviously as you'll remember this
resulted in the so-called pandemic that
happened over summer when as many as a
hundred thousand of these alerts were
being sent out every day but it is a key
weapon in fighting the spread of
chronovirus the question is how many
people
are still using this contact training
app to alert their contacts to a
positive test and the figures i've been
looking at indicates probably not enough
in england and wales for example only
about half about 50 percent of people
who've downloaded the app are using it
to alert their close contacts and north
of the border in scotland things are
even worse it's only about one in five
about 20 of people who've downloaded the
app are using it to alert their close
contacts and that's really
got covered available of the answers to
that a key answer is through the app
there are other ways of finding out if
you've been close to somebody who's
tested positive so there's the nhs test
and trace system but that's quite
labor-intensive
the idea of the app is less
labor-intensive more widespread way of
getting the word out and according to
these figures not enough people are
using the app in the way that it was
intended and that's obviously going to
have a knock-on effect in terms of
isolation
this monastery is under the protections
of russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magne and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
they can't arrest everybody
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back now the bank of england has
announced a rise in interest rates from
0.1 to 0.25
it follows a recent surge in inflation
which rose to more than five percent
last month well in a moment our expert
panel we'll be back to answer all your
workplace covid uh questions but first
let's go to our economics and data
editor ed conway he's going to explain
why rates are on the rise and how
omicron could only add to the problem
once again just before christmas the
economy is frozen no lockdown no
emergency support but hospitality
feeling the effects of omicron we're
told to stay open but we can't afford to
stay open and no one's coming so
so you're essentially condemning a whole
industry to
to to just
sit still this restaurant has had to
close its doors just before what was
supposed to be the busiest time of the
year it's sort of our black friday
moment those last 10 days of december
when when you when you turn into from
positive from negative into positive
because there are so many costs involved
with running a restaurant
so those last three weeks are really key
but infections are not the only thing
rising fast so too are prices and in the
face of that the bank of england has
surprised markets by raising interest
rates from 0.1 to 0.25
we have to take the action that we think
will do the do the job to address
and tackle the inflationary pressure
particularly in the medium term we just
have to do that i'm afraid and obviously
we have to we have to take into account
activity in the in the economy but i
should say employment in the economy is
now very tight
if you've got a floating rate mortgage
or savings product you should notice the
change soon but for most households the
direct impact should be minimal
if you're after one chart that shows why
rates are going up it's this one
inflation the very thing the bank's
supposed to keep low on the left you can
see the high inflation 90s now look at
the right the bank now thinks average
prices could be rising at an annual rate
of six percent by next april that would
be the highest rate since 1992 when
interest rates were over 10 percent
in short the bank's betting that the
risk from inflation outweigh the risks
from omicron which is a bold call given
how little we know about what's coming
in the next few weeks and it's a big
moment because while this may be a small
increase it's potentially just the first
of many
higher inflation higher interest rates
just as many households around the
country are feeling perilously squeezed
and few households are feeling it more
than so-called mortgage prisoners
hundreds of thousands of people who
simply can't get onto a cheaper deal
john is trapped on a 4.8 mortgage and
fears it'll now go above five percent so
i would say it's going to rise again so
you've got that in the back of your mind
also um so the opportunity cost of of
not only being a mortgage prisoner but
that additional rise
you can't even put it into words at the
moment it's it's terrifying it's going
to affect not only does it affect us
every month in the money we have to pay
the opportunity cost affects our
children you know and all the things
that they should be doing that we can't
afford to do because we're paying more
for a mortgage
covered omicron higher inflation and now
interest rates not the presents anyone
asked for but once again christmas is
looking
complicated ed conway sky news
well straight back to our guests with
your uh questions to put uh to them and
this one i'd like to put uh to more than
one of you so if it's possible just try
and and keep it short i know that's hard
because there's a lot to get in there uh
so the question is i have a reasonably
uh sorry the question is the test and
trace app uh has been called a key
weapon against covid uh so why are we
not being encouraged to turn it back on
uh and i'd like to start with dr claudia
uh paolini on that would you like to see
it being turned back on much
more i think one of the difficulties
you've got is as soon as the virus is um
transmitting as quickly as it is and so
many people are infected it becomes a
lot more difficult to actually work so
the contact tracing for instance becomes
more difficult um it it's the numbers
it's all around numbers and i think um
the the best things that we can do as
individuals uh wash our hands keep our
distance and put those face masks on i
can't emphasize enough how that's really
important for people to do
dr rajiv ali we're hearing uh reports
that some of those who are testing
positive with omicron don't have the app
installed on their phone it's hard
to get their their contact traces and to
get in touch uh with them how much of a
problem do you think that is
i think one of the reasons people
stopped using it is because of the
so-called pandemic over the summer and
people are worried
that they won't be able to go to work or
to attend events and obviously with
christmas coming up they're even more
concerned but the rules have changed now
um and if you are
contacted by the testing tradeoff or get
pinged then you can you've got the
alternative of taking daily natural flow
tests and as long as those tests are
negative you can carry on with you know
with your work and and other engagements
so i would encourage people to to use
the app and of course if they're
contacted by test and trace um then they
should follow those rules and take those
daily lateral flow tests okay and i'm
seeing nodding from professor moss there
as well so uh try and use that app if
you can uh well listen as we're talking
about uh the health of the economy uh
just earlier uh with ed conway uh we've
also heard from the chancellor rishi
tsunak about supporting businesses uh at
this critical time let's have a listen
to him
well i appreciate that it is a difficult
time for the hospitality industry that's
why i was on the phone earlier today
with various industry leaders from the
hospitality space and the good news i
would say is that there is existing
support measures in place to help the
industry for example
until spring of next year most
businesses in the hospitality industry
are only paying a quarter of their
normal business rates bill they are
benefiting from a reduced rate of vat
all the way through to next spring and
thirdly there is about quarter of a
billion pounds of cash sitting with
local authorities that's been provided
by government to support those
businesses who need it and my immediate
priority is to make sure that that money
gets to those businesses as quickly as
possible
there you go you heard from the
chancellor back to our guests back to
your questions that are coming through
thick and fast uh we have one here that
again i'd like to put to a couple of you
so uh try and keep it brief if you can
uh it's a it's a tough one this one my
boss is ignoring work from home guidance
because he thinks omicron is mild
why isn't the government introducing
mandatory restrictions uh let's start uh
professor paul moss you've attended some
of those sage meetings given advice
talked about these sorts of issues
why is the government not giving
stronger advice so that people aren't
pressured into situations that that they
potentially could be uncomfortable with
it's a very very important question i i
totally agree people should not be
pressured um we there's certainly not
enough evidence yet to know that this
virus is mild it's far too early to say
as um
which he said yesterday we know a lot
about the virus so far most of it's bad
so i think we have to be incredibly
cautious uh we have a clear work from
home where possible mandate so i would
urge all employers to stick to that um
because that's wise practice
okay uh simon could i'm very aware we've
not come to you yet uh there haven't
been as many travel questions we've got
a whole section coming up on that uh but
i'd like to get your thoughts on that
this idea of mandatory restrictions
other countries are doing it what do
they think of the uk when they look and
they think it's all up to us to decide
what we want to do
well there is whenever you travel around
europe or indeed further afield there is
this idea that um the uk is taking a
rather well certainly an outlier in
terms of um the restrictions in the uk a
lot of people i talk to who come to the
uk or whether on business or to see
family are absolutely astonished at what
they find
however
i think it's important to just put this
into perspective it's three weeks ago
tonight that we first heard about this
variant well i'm sure our excellent
medical figures knew about it but it
didn't even have a name then um about
this time in the evening we suddenly
heard that there was going to be a
flight ban on south africa because of
this variant and look at where we are
now um since then of course the uk has
put in some very tough uh rules we had
11 countries on the red list that ended
at 4 a.m yesterday but we still have the
pre-departure test that everybody
turning up here at newcastle airport
from abroad has had to take and on top
of that um uh so pre-departure lateral
flow and then a pcr test and you've got
to go straight home and self-isolate
until you've got a a negative result for
that and a lot of people are saying well
actually the rules for travelers are
among the toughest in europe if not the
toughest um the rules for uh just normal
daily life are actually um very relaxed
so there's a kind of bit of a mismatch
having said that i dare say half your
viewers and possibly our excellent panel
we're all saying why is anybody
traveling at the height of a pandemic no
well certainly a question we'll come to
uh after the break thanks very much
simon calder there and uh to our panel
you're watching a sky news omicron q a
special coming up after the break
bad news for many holiday makers but
could there be more travel disruption to
come thanks to omicron we'll be
discussing
yeah we heard the news this morning and
it was pretty devastating really we've
had to tell the kids they won't be going
um we're frantically ringing around
trying to
claw back what money we can
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back now it was perhaps
inevitable france closed its doors to
british tourists just ahead of the ski
season the uk's nearest neighbor on the
continent blames its huge rates of
omicron for the change
but this is largely down to effective
british testing identifying the variant
at the question
will other holiday destinations follow
suit well our europe correspondent
michelle clifford explains the
implications of france's travel
restrictions
[Music]
there will be something missing from the
leo christmas market in the coming days
many of the british tourists the traders
usually enjoy seeing france's decision
to halt non-essential travel from the uk
will mean lost profits not just at the
stalls but from the hotels and
restaurants in the city a lucky few did
make it into france before the new curbs
come in there was huge relief in the leo
eurostar station
i have terminal cancer so this is my
last holiday abroad so i've got months
we've come for the weekend to go to
disneyland i was really relieved that i
was able to get here in time and not be
told that i can't come here anymore so i
can see my sister who lives and works
here
but plenty of would-be tourists have
been left devastated including the
kohl's family who should have been
hitting the ski slopes of france this
weekend
had to tell the kids they won't be going
um we're frantically ringing around
trying to
claw back what money we can
not just in terms of um what the trip
has cost us but also covid tests
transfers
skiing lessons all of those things that
we've booked that have come at great
cost christmas plans for thousands are
likely to be affected as come saturday
people who are not french residents or
citizens will have to have a compelling
reason to travel from the uk but the
french government insists the measures
are necessary because of high rates of
the omicron variant in the uk
tourism
will restrict the entry of tourists and
business people without french or eu
nationality people coming to france from
the uk will have to isolate themselves
in a location of their choice for seven
days
there won't just be emotional and
financial pain for disappointed tourists
but for ferry companies and airlines as
trips are cancelled at what should be
one of the busiest periods of the year
the travel ban has affected us by
effectively wiping out our christmas
season we have around 22 000 passengers
who are booked with revenue of roughly 2
million that um that we will lose
france is taking a hard line against
non-essential travel from the uk
tourists hoping to spend some of
christmas here are being told to stay
away and the big question now is whether
other eu nations will follow suit
dashing the holiday plans of many
the festive period may not prove quite
as merry as many from the uk had hoped
michelle clifford sky news leo
uh well let's go straight uh back to our
guests with some questions uh on
holidays this first question uh i'd like
to put actually to both simon calder and
also uh dr rajeev ali so just bear that
in mind the two of you as i ask it uh
are we being penalized i can imagine a
disgruntled holiday maker perhaps asking
this question are we the brits being
penalized for being good at identifying
the variant uh so let's uh begin with
simon colder on this do you think
there's a political uh angle to this as
well are we being penalized for being
good at the science
well i i will leave that to our
excellent medical team to to explain
that but there is certainly a political
aspect to all these decisions and it
became clear actually with the transport
select committee yesterday um that uh
the british government um like probably
the french government takes a political
view of uh
of uh travel restrictions as well
but so interesting i mean the point that
michelle clifford's report made there
was should we all be worried about the
possibility that this is going to happen
and the other places will look at our
fantastic
uh results from genomic uh sequencing
and and do the same my view is that they
won't we had italy last night coming out
and saying yep you've got to do more
testing and that's the sort of response
that i would expect perhaps from more
countries as we get closer to christmas
um saying perhaps you know you've got to
take a test closer to your departure
maybe you've got to take a pcr test
which will be annoying and expensive and
stressful rather than a lateral flow
test maybe even when you get here you're
going to be self-isolating until you've
got a negative test result
but something like a complete travel ban
as we've seen from france i think is an
outlier and i do not expect that we will
see that so if you are heading to spain
uh to italy to switzerland to the us um
i would be prepared for travel changes
to the travel um to the testing
arrangements but nothing else and just
on that subject in that report from
michelle we heard about somebody who was
trying to claim back money from testing
um please don't book tests until the
very last minute because i've just
people are losing hundreds and hundreds
of pounds booking tests that they simply
cannot use i'm afraid that's fantastic
advice thank you simon so don't put your
tests until the last minute if you are
uh planning to travel and if you're
going to countries like spain you may be
okay well let's put that question uh to
dr uh rajiv ali as well is it a little
bit
the country the uk is now almost in a
situation like someone who's turned on
their test and trace app and actually
you're going to get pinged and you're
going to regret having turned it on we
are good at identifying the variants and
so we get punished by other countries
yeah
i mean it's a bit like that we do the
you know the most testing uh certainly
in terms of the genomic sequencing that
allows us to identify the appearance of
any country in europe but we also do a
lot more testing than almost any other
country in europe as well and that's why
when you compare these case rates it's
it's not a kind of direct comparison so
we do a lot more testing for example
than
germany france italy spain and if you
adjust for that it's likely that their
cases are are higher than ours and
omicron is everywhere now um they may
not be fighting because they're not
testing for it but it's likely that
their cases of omicron are similar or
even higher levels
than ours so i don't think it's fair to
be you know having these travel bans
we've got ways
of testing people now as we do arriving
in the uk and i think all other
countries in europe should follow
a similar policy so you test people on
arrival and if you want to test them
again
on day two three four five of course
that's a huge country to decide but i
don't think there's any
justification for a travel ban
and the danger of that as we've seen
coming to south africa is that people or
companies will stop reporting when they
find these new variants because they
will feel that they are going to be
penalized and it damages particularly
you know countries poorer countries it's
it damages their tourist industry so i
think we have to be really careful to uh
you know not to have these blanket
travel restrictions and to move forward
in the future with with testing and
quarantine where required absolutely a
really interesting point there on where
the political meets the scientific
thanks very much dr ali there uh more
with our panel in just a moment but next
the prime minister denied claims that
he's introducing another lockdown by
stealth in response to the alarming rise
in cases while telling people not to
cancel christmas the prime minister's
chief medical officer told the nation to
exercise caution cutting down on social
contacts and it calls some back bench
stories to accuse the government of
allowing health advisers to run the show
well our deputy political editor sam
coats has the latest on the arguments
over the covid restrictions
[Applause]
keeping the country moving in sync at
christmas boris johnson still banking on
the booster to save us from more curbs
and more restrictions
here at a vaccine center in kent this
morning celebrating 25 million jabs
which he boasts is keeping england
unlocked
we don't want to make your choices for
you about your social life
uh we're not closing things but what we
are saying is people should be cautious
and they should think about uh their
activities in the in the run-up to
to christmas nobody wants to uh to get
omicron and be unwell and be forced to
to isolate
pm isn't forcing many measures in
england but others are tightening the
screw and demanding more after another
leap in daily cases medics are making
clear behaving normally is too risky i
wouldn't want to
say to people they should do a
particular thing they should do this or
they should do that this is about saying
to people look this is a period to
prioritize
chief medical officer chris witte clear
that more restrictions could be on the
cards if it looked as if the vaccines
were less effective than we were
expecting i think that for example would
be a material change to how ministers
viewed the risks going forward
today the prime minister catching up
with the sultan of oman as many others
suggested the pm could or should go
further
are there going to be more restrictions
within days prime minister is
hospitality you think the current
situation can hold for long
government scientists say that omicron
poses perhaps the most significant
threat since the start of the pandemic
but boris johnson says that his
relatively mild curbs are enough
mps don't trust that he won't go further
however
i understand that discussions have taken
place at the top of government about
much more severe restrictions but will
the prime minister end up disappointing
his party
or his scientists
tory mps don't like what they're hearing
from the scientists or the consequences
that follow
i fear that we are treading a path back
to a full-on lockdown we saw this last
christmas christmas will be fine we were
told then christmas all of a sudden
wasn't fine we had the rule of six then
it was down to actually no rule of six
don't mix at all for huge parts of the
country and i fear history will repeat
itself
this christmas i very much hope it
doesn't
but if we do go down that path
the government have got to have thought
through the measures they are going to
bring in to mitigate it
that means help lots of it for pubs
restaurants and all those sectors hit by
warnings to sit at home
not least because limits have been put
in place outside england in scotland
people have been told to limit
gatherings to three households
pre-christmas while more rules are
expected to be announced in wales
tomorrow leaders of both nations want
more financial help this now needs the
urgent engagement of the prime minister
and the chancellor we must not sleepwalk
into an emergency that for both health
and business will be much greater as a
result of inaction than it will be if we
act firmly and strongly now these people
are doing what they're told and getting
jabbed to stay free but will boris
johnson be able to deliver on his end of
the bargain sam coach sky news
westminster
you're watching us guy news omicron q a
special coming up with people staying
home the arts and entertainment industry
faces another reckoning
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
[Music]
we saw snatchbots going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
[Music]
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with
us over the past 24 hours the soldiers
have been attacked on a number of
occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we'd be
impressed to take you to the heart of
stories that shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked
[Music]
when enormous explosions just come down
i think it was a monster just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello again now whether it's football
games theater performances omicron is
causing the closure of many events and
even for those productions that have
managed to stay open uh there is still
the challenge of breaking even uh with
empty seats well our arts and
entertainment correspondent katie
spencer has been looking at the struggle
for businesses
we've been told to try to put our
christmas plans on ice
the tinsel's up lights are twinkling
should we even be out not causing any
plans a little bit wild about being out
but
we're going to go ahead we've got his
masks we've got a sanitizer in his his
bags we've got his call with passes
so
yeah i'm not worried at all the
government has said it wants to avoid
making choices for people but don't mix
if you don't have to so does that mean
we're entering lockdown by stealth in
london it's certainly starting to feel
like that we're actually meant to be
going to france today to go skiing so
we've had to cancel that
shows are called off at the lion king
covered enforced absences among caste
and crew is the reason and this isn't
the only theater that's been forced to
put performances on pause
leading voices within the industry are
worried audiences being put off and
coming
we we want to be healthy like everyone
else we want to beat this variant but we
also want to protect our businesses
[Music]
lots of schools christmas celebrations
are playing out virtually
[Music]
[Applause]
the gigs and the live music sector from
cancellations to covered passes the
consequences are crippling you've got
people playing out concerts you're
having to cancel gigs because of
musicians getting covered and so there's
real uncertainty and there's lots of
organizations in the sector that are
basically look staring at the brink
of course placing responsibility in our
hands means the government doesn't have
to take responsibility for businesses
financially which through no fault of
their own are taking a big hit
if our priority is to make it to the
christmas dinner table with family we're
told we've got to make choices about
what we do and where we go after this
week i won't be going out anymore next
week so i want to keep everyone safe for
christmas
simple words with consequences that
could prove financially catastrophic for
those businesses that rely on people
going out
katie spencer sky news
well we've got a fair few questions to
get through with our guests now our
expert panel not much time so i'm going
to ask you to keep it very very brief as
we go through these the first question
given the apparent milder symptoms of
the omicron variant are we overreacting
let's put that to dr claudia paolini you
see uh this on the front line are we
overreacting
it's too early to say we don't know we
don't actually have that data to say
that it is milder or much milder and
even if it is and let's hope it is but a
small percentage being affected and
resulting in hospital admissions of a
very large number because it spreads so
much is still going to cause huge
problems within the nhs and overwhelm us
and that will be a a a massive economic
impact as well in itself um because of
the costs that that will require to to
keep going okay uh professor paul moss
let's put that to you as well is the
vaccine program up to fighting uh
omicron
yes i i believe so i mean i don't think
we're overacting i think we're preparing
for the worst but hoping for the best
and the next three or four weeks will be
critical in assessing how things go so i
think what we're doing is entirely right
we're trying to minimize contact and
spread and we're trying to boost
immunity and get hospitals in great
shape so i think what we're doing is
very appropriate okay
the next question is omicron just a less
dangerous variant out competing the more
deadly ones uh dr rajiv ali given what
you know about omicron so far
does that sound right
so we don't know uh yet we've got data
from london suggesting that both omicron
and delta
are circulating uh in south africa
omicron has taken it from delta they
have very low levels of delta in the
first place so we'll just have to wait
and see really what happens in the uk as
to whether that has happened previously
on the context over from delta or the
two co-circulate for a while just one
other quick point i wanted to make i
mean it's important that your viewers
understand that their personal risk
um is much much lower than it was this
time last year when no one had had
vaccines and i think it's important that
people understand you know that we are
much better protected whether you've had
two doses or three doses you're in a
much better position than you were last
year i know there's a lot of fear around
um and the concern we have of course
with the nhs is that we'll have so many
cases in a short period of time but for
the individual person you are much worse
of course you still take all the
precautions will be talking about but
you shouldn't be living in you know in
fear for your own personal risk okay
that's really good to know
we have a question here about uh the
young particularly how is omicron
affecting uh those especially at a young
age i wonder dr claudio uh claudio
paulini if you've seen uh any evidence
on that thus far
no there's still no evidence around that
at the moment but there's no reason for
us to think that it's a affecting
younger children or younger adults um
any more so than the delta variants so
no there isn't any evidence around that
okay professor paul most you want to add
to that at all
no i'd agree with that i mean there was
some study initially from south africa
that seemed to be affecting children a
little bit more severely
more hospitalizations but i don't think
death thankfully but we're not really
seeing that in the uk at the moment of
course a great wave of omicron does seem
to be in sort of 20 to 40 or 50 year
olds at the moment
and just we just hope that if it when it
gets into the older population who are
highly vaccinated and boosted of course
that they will be protected okay thank
you very much we have uh honestly 30
seconds left for this i just tested
positive on covid uh for covid will i be
able to see my family on christmas uh
day uh dr rajivali
i mean of course you have to go through
the 10 days of isolation if you've
tested positive so you may just miss out
christmas day but you know you will be
able to visit them this year we have got
four day kind of break from the 25th to
the uh
to the 28th so you can just wait a
couple more days and visit family after
you've completed those 10 days okay well
i'm sorry to have to to make you deliver
that bad news thank you very much that
is all we have time for in our omicron q
a special it just leaves us time to say
a huge thank you to our panel they uh
were professor paul moss
dr rajeev ali
dr claudia paulini
and simon calder thank you
and thank you at home for all of your
questions i hope we answered them up
next on sky news tonight boris johnson
denies claims that he is imposing a
lockdown by stealth
[Music]
foreign